you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now all
right but now back to reality
we're keeping this eye on the sky this
is our camera on top of the Red Rock
Resort way out on the west side of town
yeah the palm trees whipping around
great view of the strip but the cloud
deck overhead trying to do some rain and
we may get some sprinkles before all is
said and done we're anticipating little
or no accumulation except for up on
Mount Charleston got that wind advisory
also the wind advisory for the Lakes now
68 degrees is the official temperature
this hour added Reed so we get warm
temperatures ahead of the wind so the
wind is starting to kick up gusts close
to 30 miles an hour hasn't quite reached
the other side of town the Air Force
Base hanging at 60 61 for Seven Hills we
look outside of Southern Nevada to
Nevada and Beyond Death Valley 55 warmer
and Loft again at 61. Caliente you're at
52 scattered showers going to be across
the northern and Central parts of the
silver state you know what if we get to
70 today which could happen that would
tie the record high for today's date
from 1980 low this morning at 49. so
while we are going concerned about
what's going on here and certainly some
rain mixed with snow over the northern
Rockies the bigger storm for New Year's
Eve still winding up up over the Gulf of
Alaska but this is the big story for now
as Buffalo gets a chance to try to clean
up from the ongoing storm here's your
most accurate eight day forecast windy
today with a chance for sprinkles
lingering into tomorrow the breezes
remain we get a couple of days off with
a lot of cloud cover Thursday Friday but
the last day of 2022 might have better
chances for rain that could impact the
New Year's Eve celebrations we'll
certainly keep it posted with high
temperatures dropped back to the 50's to
welcome in the New Year John all right
we'll keep an eye out Nate thank you sir